- This season is
so fucking good,
it is the best season so far,
it's gonna be like
the joy that we need
in this evil moment in history.
Welcome to (bleep)'s America.
- We had infused this new tone
throughout this season
to reflect what happened
in the election,
and so we were going
to be saying his name,
and talking about him,
because we felt like
these characters, they're
gonna be talking about it
and dealing with it
just like we are.
And it also felt right
to just not say his name.
We don't wanna say his name.
- Yeah, we're just
sitting around talking about it,
and we're like,
"Ecch, ew, gross.
He sucks. He's so hateful,
I don't even wanna
fucking say his name."
- I'm sure some people hate
that we're bleeping his name.
- Yeah, I just don't
think they watch the show.
- Yes, I don't think
they watch the show.
- I don't think those
people wanna see
two women be like gnarly.
- They don't wanna
see two women at all.
- (laughs) Yeah.
Get me back to New York,
where everybody
hates Donald (bleep)
- My name's Angelique Clark,
I'm the production
designer of Broad City.
A really fun idea that Ilana
had was to do a headboard
out of protest
signs and stickers.
I also put some
protest posters in,
you know, just as if
they went and protested,
and then they, like,
kept the signs,
anything anti-(bleep).
- You don't know how
much you need that.
New York is totally different
in the winter and the summer.
- Interesting how
many different coats
you can wear at once.
- The winter's intense,
it's a dark time.
- We were missing a whole
other side of the city.
Could we put the top back up?
- It's frozen in place. I tried.
When you have a good night
in the winter in New York,
you're, like, so grateful,
'cause you're just like mostly
just working, and drinking.
And drinking just makes
you more depressed.
It's horrible. We deal
with winter depression,
which is very real.
Every winter, all
winter. And fall.
And, like, uh, the
end of summer, too.
Well I wanted to do one
more, like, smaller.
We've wanted to experience
directing, it's awesome.
We're each directing two.
It really is, like this final
puzzle piece is clicking in.
- You have to be in
the scene as an actor,
but also conscious of the
whole scene as a director,
so it's different, but
I really like it so far.
Whether we're in
the scene or not,
the other person's
always in Video Village
making sure the scene
goes the way we want,
and they're like giving
pitches or thoughts.
- And Lilly Burns, one of
our executive producers,
we have such a
shorthand with her,
so if we're both on screen
and one of us is directing,
Lilly's this, like, set of eyes
that is like one of
us. It's awesome.
- You gonna tell
'em about Leanne?
(laughs) Okay, there is
this Easter egg of a joke.
We walk into this karaoke
bar to follow this guy.
There's a man singing a
song that's called "Leanne."
- ♪ Leanne, We are Leanne ♪
- It is a song that we made up,
and our music supervisor
Matt FX produced.
- One more time.
♪ Lee ♪
- [Together] ♪ Ann ♪
♪ I am Lee Ann.
We're all Lee Ann. ♪
Something like that.
(laughs)
- (laughs) And it plays
throughout the entire season.
On the radio, in cabs, it
plays the entire season.
- In "Mushrooms,"
when Abbi's like,
changing the music
and, like, nervous.
- (sighs)
It goes,
- [Together] ♪ Lee Ann ♪
- ♪ Lee Ann ♪
- ♪ I am Lee Ann ♪
- ♪ We are Lee Ann ♪
- (laughs) It's so stupid.
- [RuPaul] Kick fuck me.
Put your fuckin' foot
in my god damn pussy. You know?
- Start again.
(laughs) This is such
a dream come true.
Working with RuPaul
Charles was such a dream.
- I think the character is
more stern than Ru actually is.
- And also containing
him into, like,
the manager of a restaurant,
I've been watching RuPaul
on TV for my entire life.
- [Brenda] (groaning in pain)
- Brenda, I'm so sorry.
- You did it on
purpose, you bitch. Ow.
- It's always great
to see the evolution
with women in comedy.
- It's so exciting
working with these women.
- I studied her as a
kid and a comedy nerd,
she kept throwing in,
like, surprising improv.
She's amazing.
- As fate would have it,
today we have Shania Twain
as a guest.
- Man, I feel like a smoothie.
- She was so funny,
she was so down
to play with herself as an icon.
She like riffs this song.
- ♪ When there's a spark
you gotta ride it. ♪
- ♪ Dow naw. ♪
- ♪ When you're in love,
don't hide it. Ooh! ♪
- [Together] I love "Friends."
- I'm such a Chandler.
- I'm such a Ross.
- Total Rachel.
Little Gunther, also.
Trey Pucker is the lead
character on "Broad City."
The show, obviously,
is about a trainer
and his life and struggles.
And yeah, it's a show,
I think that shows
what life is like in New
York for a healthy fit man,
and two women he knows.
- You threw a glass
bowl into traffic?
- Oh yeah, done and done.
- When I started, you
know, it was sort of like
first wave of post-feminist
ideas in comedy
and doing work that was
not self-deprecating,
that was not cliche.
Each generation takes
it to another level.
It's really impressive and
important and exciting.
- It's good to see
just how they've grown
as actors, as business
women, as creators.
- There's a feeling on
the set, you feel free,
you feel safe, so it's
a pleasure being here.
- It means a lot to people,
and I think it's cool
to have two women who are
just fucking hilarious
crushing the comedy game.
- It's great because
the show is written
by a small group of us
who are really close,
and who are all
friends, and I think
when people watch the show,
one of the things they
like most about it
is how authentic it feels,
because Abbi and Ilana
are really close friends.
- Broad City was my
first big gig. You know?
And after that,
other stuff has come.
But, like, I haven't
found a sense of family
or a sense of belonging
like I do here.
You know what I mean?
- My love for you is
sometimes inappropriate.
I love you.
- Love you too.
- Keep me posted (kiss)
Love ya.
- I love you too.
- Some people you are
just destined to meet
and fall in love with.
- (both laughing)
♪ We are Leanne. ♪
- [Together] Woo!
♪ You are Leanne.
We are Leanne. ♪